[Musique]
depuis mercredi des milliers
d'entrepreneurs et d'acteurs politiques
discutent du monde économique post crise
sanitaire
et parmi eux vladimir poutine le
président russe est revenu il y assure
la récession planétaire lié au corona
virus ainsi que les vaccins anti coville
ou encore les relations moscou
washington sirène benavides payant et de
trois heures des changes pour vladimir
poutine président hôte du forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg moments
forts de cette intervention le président
a évoqué le sommet du 16 juin à genève
avec son homologue joe biden il souhaite
améliorer les relations particulièrement
tendues entre les deux puissances
pourquoi les nos partenaires américains
agissent de cette façon pour moi c'est
toujours assez énigmatique je suis même
convaincu qu'il s'agit en premier lieu
d'un processus politique interne aux
états unis et que les relations russo
américaines sont prises en otage dans ce
système et j'espère qu'un jour ça va
finir et que les intérêts en matière de
sécurité de stabilité stratégique de
réduction des armements qui sont
dangereux pour tout le magne et et je
pense que cela sera un plus important
que la conjoncture économique politique
interne aux états unis autre information
majeure de cette séance plénière la fin
des constructions de la première ligne
du gazoduc nord stream 2 qui relie la
russie à l'allemagne
la pose des tubes a pris fin sur le
secteur maritime du 'pipeline' la
seconde conduite sera achevé d'ici à
deux mois au maximum
et c'est le fournisseur de gaz russe
gazprom qui sera chargée de la remplir
ça a été la pose du gazoduc north stream
2 vient d'être achevée et pourquoi je
dis ça parce que c'est de le système le
plus le plus avancé du point de vue
technologique et cet itinéraire va
relier le système le système national en
russie et l'allemagne
donc tout cela fait en sorte que nous
avons des approvisionnements sûrs
fiables vers l'europe
enfin vladimir poutine a mentionné la
question des vaccins
il considère que spoutnik v n'est
toujours pas sur le marché européen pour
des raisons d'intérêts politiques et
économiques au détriment des citoyens
notamment européens
le chef de l'état russe a donc plaidé
pour un accès généralisé au vaccin sur
tous les continents
alors que seulement 10% de la population
mondiale est vaccinée